so Ben Shapiro I guess has like a
temporary like a seasonal show of sorts
on Fox News that's related to the
upcoming midterm election and the there
has been a segment that there's been a
couple segments actually that ben
shapiro has done one on this fox show
and also in prior programming that ben
shapiro has done about socialism or
social democracy or Marxism or communism
and it's sort of hard to tell which one
it is that he's talking about at
different points and we're gonna go
through some videos and the point i want
to make to you here is that there is
sort of a deliberate simultaneous
confusion and confounding that is being
done by ben shapiro and others this is
emblematic of what many others are doing
where they are both miss stating what
socialism and social democracy and
Marxism are but also making bad
arguments against them and there's
really no better way to explain this to
you than to show you some of the clips
that we have so this is from the fox
news show that ben shapiro has been
doing and you can tell from the start
that there's just something wrong with
the presentation there's just like
fundamental factual knowledge that seems
to be either missing or being
deliberately ignored let's start with
clip number one norway has become the
favorite democratic socialist test case
for the american left venezuela people
are eating dogs in the streets and
Cuba's going out of fashion turns out
that when people are floating 1950's
Chevy's into the Atlantic Ocean a kind
of a bad sign so the argument here is
that you've got Norway and Venezuela and
Cuba and they're all Marxist or so he
sort of initially suggests but then
later he'll kind of go back with that
and that Norway is going okay but
Venezuela and Cuba are not so that what
the left does is cherry-pick and ignore
Venezuela and Cuba and only talk about
Norway so just that one idea would be
worthy of like an hour of analysis or at
least a half hour but the main points
here are number one actual progressives
should talk about the failings of
Venezuela in Cuba I do it all the time
there are people on the Left who hate me
for that it's become sort of like a
litmus test for the the litmus test left
likes to criticize others who talk about
Venezuela
Cuba the Leninist left call it whatever
you want but Venezuela and Cuba are
authoritarian takeovers of society with
populist left-wing rhetoric and as a
progressive social democrat I'm opposed
to that and I talk about the problems
there but then there's the real
distortion which is that anyone is
saying Norway is Marxist and Ben Shapiro
will eventually say Norway's not
actually Marxist and so the left is also
wrong about that Norway has good and bad
things going on quite a bit of good but
Norway is a social democracy in the sort
of standard scandinavian model period so
to claim that even people on the left
are saying it's marxist to even mention
norway when talking about Marxism is a
joke norway is not even socialist
nevermind communist or marxist and then
ben shapiro immediately goes on to say
but norway isn't actually Marxist anyway
they're just a few problems with this
perspective first off Norway isn't
socialist it's a capitalist country
burdened with massively expensive
socialist redistribution programs okay
so in the first clip he says Marxist and
now he says it's not actually socialist
that's obvious right I don't talk to any
serious people on the Left who say that
Norway is an example of a socialist
success or a communist success or a
Marxist success it's a social democracy
it's capitalism right and that is a
fundamental distortion here he also has
talked about actual social democracy
democratic socialism and some of these
same confusions exist let's look at
another clip now let's talk for a second
about the appeal of democratic socialism
because when you hear from the left of
the democratic socialism is what exists
in places like Denmark and Sweden that
is real socialism there's only one
problem none of this is true nema son
Anton ji who writes for the stream he
has a very good piece about myths
regarding Nordic socialism he's an
author and researcher heald's PhD from
the Royal Institute of Technology in
Sweden and conducted research at the at
the University of Cambridge and he has a
great piece about why it is that so many
people think that Democratic Socialist
Republics are the ones that are really
succeeding when in reality they're
succeeding in spite of their socialism
so here's what he says the success of
Nordic countries is based on the fact
that historically they have relied on
free markets
protection of private property the only
exception is a short period in Sweden
where in socialist policies crippled
growth and job creation Nordic nations
do have high taxes and generous welfare
but in many other regards nave unusually
free markets that's exactly right
they have free markets they have
relatively high taxes they have lots of
social welfare programs that's not a
debunking of socialism
it's just confirming what social
democracy is right it's capitalism
combined with strong social welfare he's
acting like the writer he cites has
found some glitch in democratic
socialism arguments no it's merely a
definition of social democracy it's what
social democracy claims to be and is we
can define social democracy many ways
but it's a mixed ideology that promotes
a progressive Democratic Pro social
justice polity with a capitalist economy
period and then again he does more of
the same conflation Danish Prime
Minister Lars Rasmussen says after
seeing his country held up as an example
in the American presidential debate he
told students in a 2015 speech at
Harvard's Kennedy School of Government
quote I know that some people in the
u.s. associate the Nordic model with
some sort of socialism therefore I would
like to make one thing clear
Denmark is far from a socialist planned
economy Denmark is a market economy when
it comes to areas such as business
regulations trade policy investment
freedom vouchers in the provision of
education elderly care and health care
and partial privatization of retirement
savings Nordic countries are among the
most free market in the world that's
right holding up Norway or Denmark as
socialist countries is wrong but they
are the definition of social democracy
and this is what's missing from the
conversation it is a false debate that
is being sort of framed here one more
clip hey Nordic countries did not become
rich by relying on socialism Sweden is
the only Nordic country that actually
experimented with socialism in the 70s
and 80s and instead it destroyed so it's
destroyed Sweden's economy that's right
they didn't become rich by being
socialist they became rich by allowing
for the creativity and innovation of
capitalism while understanding the
limits of capitalism in some markets
spending enough on social programs to
have as many citizens as possible able
to afford being part of that capitalist
economy because they're not paying off
medical bills or student loans this
constant back and forth between talking
about socialism and democratic socialism
and Marxism and mix
terms and pretending to be debunking
something when you're actually
confirming at all while speaking really
fast and with an indignant tone it works
really well and on people and then
there's this really important thing that
we shouldn't forget
and finally important to note that if
you're talking about why Denmark does
better Sweden does better Scandinavian
Americans do Scandinavia does better
important to note all of these groups
when they come to America do better in
the United States and they do back in
their home countries so in Denmark
Danish Americans actually do better in
America than they do in Denmark so all
of the talk about how how all of these
countries are thriving because of
socialism is just as intro now again he
says they're not thriving in socialism
but these are social democracies and
this is really important he says Danish
people do better as Danish Americans
when they move here than back in Denmark
how you measure that is a serious
question and what does it mean to even
do better they have a higher salary here
because if that's the argument you've
got to add in when you calculate their
Danish salary the health care and the
education that they get in Denmark that
needs to be added to their Danish salary
if you really want to compare and then
you've got to adjust for purchasing
power and you've got to consider
self-reported happiness and life
satisfaction if we're just comparing
salaries if that's what we're doing it
really tells us very very very little
about whether Danes do better in Denmark
or in the United States so I could go on
but the most important things are around
this issue number one don't get confused
by social democracy versus socialism
because they want you to be confused
okay number two don't let other people
tell you which system of government a
country has in the context of debunking
that system of government you've got to
figure out for yourself if they're
actually honestly representing what
system of government exists there and
then thirdly please look this stuff up
for yourself because there are some
really important conversations happening
around these issues and if you even
allow someone like ben shapiro to set
the the boundaries and frame the debate
for you you are by definition going to
come out extraordinarily uninformed send
me your thoughts i'm on twitter at d
pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show today's program sponsored in
part by Blink is comm slash Pakman I've
talked about blinkers before it's this
awesome app that I've been using for
several months now and what it does
take the best and most critically
acclaimed non-fiction books and
condenses them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to in one sitting
you could listen to ten books in an
afternoon I know that many in our
audience want to expand their horizons
and learn more about all sorts of
different topics but we're mostly
limited by time to some degree I know
I'm not able to read all of the books
that I want simply because I've got
other stuff going on and that's why
blink is - such a great tool you can
absorb the most important information
and insights from the book in one
sitting and our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube click the link in the video
description and after that free trial if
you like blinka stand i think you are
going to like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month go to be li NK is t.com
slash PA k ma n